[Música]
el imperio romano el imperio español el
imperio británico
todos ellos dominaron el mundo y
terminaron cayendo
hoy vivimos en la era del imperio
americano y sí ya sé que a muchos os
molesta que nos refiramos eeuu como
america pero sin embargo todos sabemos a
lo que nos referimos cuando hablamos de
imperio americano ningún otro país puede
desafiar su poder militar con bases en
lugares tan remotos como guam que es una
isla perdida en mitad del pacífico y
creedme esas bases militares son
realmente útiles
verás el hecho de que puedas ir a
cualquier tienda de tu barrio y comprar
un teléfono móvil fabricado en corea del
sur es gracias a la globalización sí
pero esa globalización no sería posible
si el comercio no fuera seguro
y todas esas bases militares
estadounidenses son las que garantizan
que se puedan enviar productos de un
sitio a otro sin ser atacados de hecho
esta es la razón por la que eeuu se
gasta tantísimo dinero en ejército
necesitan tener más presencia militar
que nadie y estar en todos los rincones
del mundo y hasta ahora lo han
conseguido
sin embargo las cosas están cambiando
hay alguien que está desafiando a este
imperio de quién estamos hablando exacto
de china y como lo están intentando en
este vídeo te lo vamos a contar
[Aplausos]
[Música]
os voy a hacer una pregunta por qué
creéis que eeuu tiene el ejército más
grande del mundo pensando bien en
realidad a duras penas necesitan tener
defensa fijaos en este mapa
[Música]
eeuu tiene una protección natural dos
enormes océanos que hacen que sea
prácticamente imposible invadir les
habéis oído bien enviar tropas para
atacar este país es prácticamente una
misión imposible pero sin embargo eeuu
es el país que más gasta en defensa su
ejército es el más grande del mundo con
bases militares en 70 países de todo el
planeta para que os hagáis una idea
reino unido francia y rusia juntos
tienen menos de 30 bases militares en
territorio extranjero
sin embargo fijaos en este otro mapa
[Música]
el ejército estadounidense está en todas
partes y eso significa que ningún país
del mundo se atreve a desafiarles
tal vez no exacto en el vídeo de hoy
vamos a hablar de china veréis en visual
políticos hemos hablado mil veces del
progreso económico chino son la fábrica
del mundo y muchas empresas chinas se
han convertido en los mayores rivales de
las grandes tecnológicas estadounidenses
pero hoy no vamos a hablar de economía
sino de ejército más concretamente de la
presencia militar en el mar del sur de
china y creedme no es ninguna broma
la jugada de china en el mar el fin del
crecimiento pacífico de beijing quedaos
con este término el collar de perlas
seguro que en este 2019 que empieza lo
vais a oír muy a menudo la primera vez
que se utilizó fue en el año 2005 en un
informe del departamento de la casa
blanca en este estudio se predecía que
china intentaría expandir su presencia
naval a través del océano índico en este
contexto el collar de perlas es una
metáfora donde cada perla sería una de
esas bases militares que china quiere
construir perlas que forman un collar
que llega hasta áfrica y oriente medio
donde china importa la mayor parte de
sus recursos naturales como os podéis
imaginar esta expansión militar preocupa
a todo el mundo y sobre todo a la casa
blanca y la cosa se pone mucho peor cada
vez que el gobierno chino intenta
tranquilizar a la comunidad
internacional fijaos en lo que decía el
ex presidente chino hu jin
en 2009
la carrera hacia un desarrollo pacífico
es una elección estratégica hecha por el
gobierno chino y su gente estamos en
línea con la cultura tradicional china
que ama la paz la tendencia de nuestro
tiempo y los intereses fundamentales de
china hu jintao no sé por qué pero esta
cita suena más falsa que el alma de
judas y como os podéis imaginar en lugar
de tranquilizar sirvió para asustar aún
más ya sabéis eso que dicen
excusatio non petita accusatio manifesta
pero vale ya sé lo que estaréis pensando
muchos china quiere más ejército tiene
el derecho a defenderse como cualquier
otro país porque deberíamos preocuparnos
de verdad quiere china superar al 'tío
sam' tienen posibilidades reales para
hacerlo hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes vamos a ver un poco
de historia
[Música]
lecciones del pasado acabamos de decir
que es casi imposible invadir eeuu pero
no hay reglas sin excepción
[Música]
en el año 1941 japón bombardeo el puerto
de pearl harbor en hawai y un año más
tarde el ejército nipón invadía las
islas aleutianas en alaska en ese
momento el tío sam aprendió una lección
la seguridad es solamente un estado de
ánimo y más nos vale proteger nuestros
océanos si no queremos que nos vuelvan a
invadir durante la segunda guerra
mundial el ejército estadounidense tuvo
que luchar en montones de islas del
pacífico
[Música]
islas que en muchos casos estaban
despobladas perdidas en mitad de la nada
pero que tenían un interés estratégico
enorme por ejemplo la batalla de midway
como su propio nombre indica se libró en
el atolón de midway que es uno de esos
puntos pequeñitos que vemos en el mapa
mundi y que no sabemos a ciencia cierta
si es un error de imprenta una mancha de
café o una isla real
[Música]
[Aplausos]
terminó la segunda guerra mundial y por
si alguien no lo sabe eeuu ganó pero no
se olvidaron la elección no querían que
algo así volviera a ocurrir y que
hicieron entonces pues cubrir el océano
pacifico de bases militares en todas
esas islas donde habían luchado dejaron
un cuartel con unos soldados de reserva
aviones y barcos y os preguntareis para
que quieres tener una base militar en un
atolón como el de midway de verdad es
tan importante la respuesta es que si
esas bases militares importan y mucho
pensarlo bien movilizar tropas de un
sitio a otro no es tarea fácil ni mucho
menos barata
[Música]
un barco de guerra es una ciudad
flotante con cañones en algunos casos
pueden tener hasta 5000 personas a bordo
y solo pueden recorrer entre 500 o 1000
kilómetros al día
[Aplausos]
es decir que si queremos mandar un barco
de los ángeles a shanghai necesitamos
como mínimo 10 días sin embargo si ya
tenemos una base militar en guam una
isla y mitad del pacífico podemos tener
a nuestro ejército en la costa china en
tan sólo tres días esa rapidez de
respuesta es clave para disuadir
cualquier intento de ataque en realidad
muchos de estos barcos de guerra ni
siquiera llegarán a disparar una sola
bala durante toda su vida útil y con
semejante poder de maniobra nadie se
atrevería a atacarlos son el líder
militar indiscutible y a esto lo
llamamos poder de disuasión pero no sólo
hablamos de guerra convencional
muchos de estos barcos están pensados
para combatir piratas o terroristas
por ejemplo el uss e independents es un
barco pensado para la lucha contra la
piratería pero tenemos muchos otros
barcos la marina estadounidense crece
año tras año y eso significa que nadie
más en el mundo les puede hacer sombra
a la isla y me agregara 46 barcos en
cinco años pero 355 no vendrán en mucho
tiempo por supuesto todo esto le da un
poder inmenso al imperio americano todo
esto puede ser preocupante para muchos
pero seamos honestos hasta la fecha ha
creado un marco bastante pacífico en el
mundo un entorno donde todo el mundo
puede comerciar allí donde hay unos
piratas que quieren bloquear una ruta
marítima el imperio americano está listo
para darles caza y esa es una de las
razones por la que los países del
sudeste asiático se han podido convertir
rápidamente en líderes exportadores y
por supuesto todo esto también beneficia
a china
ahora mismo vamos a ver cómo hay muchos
países en la zona que estarían
encantados de bloquear el comercio chino
y eeuu hasta ahora ha conseguido evitar
todo esto pero de verdad le gusta china
depender tanto del imperio americano
pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
una nueva hegemonía hay muchos países
que están bendecidos con recursos
naturales petróleo gas metales y todo
tipo de minerales tener recursos te da
una ventaja enorme sobre los demás
países ese es el ejemplo de arabia
saudita que es lo que es gracias a sus
enormes reservas de zumo de dinosaurio
pero qué pasa con los demás países con
esos que no tienen recursos naturales
esos países tienen que importar todo
tipo de cosas para sobrevivir necesitan
competir con los proveedores
internacionales y negociar contratos
para garantizarse sus recursos necesitan
asegurarse además de que esos recursos
llegan a tiempo y en muchos casos eso
puede ser una posición de debilidad
[Música]
pues bien este es el caso de china si
todos lo sabemos china tiene una
industria nacho vidal jana pero a duras
penas tienen recursos naturales todo su
petróleo su acero su uranio todo todo lo
que necesitan para fabricar esos
teléfonos móviles y esas televisiones
les vienen del extranjero y cada día
necesitan importar más cosas pero no
sólo eso una vez han comprado todos los
recursos tienen que transportarlos hacia
su país de forma segura y barata y por
eso el mar de china está cubierto de
barcos mercantes es la clave de la
supervivencia china y eso explica que a
china le interese tanto controlarlo
[Música]
además entender que china no tiene un
mercado doméstico tan grande como eeuu
casi todo lo que fabrican tiene que
salir de otros países para venderse y
eso significa aún más dependencia de
esas rutas marítimas y si recordáis
otros vídeos de visual política el
partido comunista chino tiene ese pacto
tácito con los ciudadanos ellos
garantizan progreso económico y a cambio
el pueblo se deja controlar y no se
queja imaginad lo que pasaría si un buen
día el partido comunista chino ya no
puede garantizar esa seguridad y ese
progreso económico
[Música]
vale ya sé lo que estáis pensando final
no es el único país que depende del
comercio internacional suiza tampoco
tiene recursos naturales y no parece que
tengan problemas verdad pues si tenéis
razón pero hay un detalle que se nos
escapa en el caso de china bastaría con
que un país bloqueara sus rutas
comerciales y toda china colapsaría en
cuestión de meses y creedme hay muchos
países deseando hacer algo así
especialmente uno la india fijaos en
este mapa veis esa ristra de islas en el
océano índico bien esas son las islas de
andamán y nicobar y son territorio indio
sería muy fácil para la india colocar un
par de barcos de guerra por esa zona y
bloquear todas las rutas que iván
petróleo a china casi todos los
petroleros que vienen de oriente medio'
pasan por el estrecho de malaca que es
donde esta singapur y para llegar ahí
primero tienen que pasar por estas islas
hablamos de casi 20 millones de barriles
de crudo al día es decir que si un día
el presidente de la india se levanta con
mal genio puede hundir a china en
cuestión de días hablamos de toda una
amenaza existencial de hecho el ex
presidente chino hu jintao se refería a
este problema como el dilema de malaca
pero no solo hablamos de la india eeuu
no es un enemigo declarado de china pero
digamos que tampoco es un aliado
incondicional si la india quisiera
bloquear el tráfico chino de qué lado se
pondría el imperio americano
[Música]
es difícil de predecir y esto podría ser
mucho peor que todas las guerras
comerciales de trump juntas así que cuál
es la solución de beijing para todo esto
pues está
[Música]
la iniciativa belt and road y su
equivalente marítimo el collar de perlas
como ya sabéis la iniciativa beltán road
comenzó con la presidencia de xi jinping
en 2013 en principio la idea es
construir infraestructuras en todo el
mundo para acelerar el crecimiento chino
pues bien el collar de perlas es la
versión marítima del bel tan road y no
creáis que hablamos de poco dinero
en 2017 xi jinping intento sumar 124 mil
millones de dólares extra para este
proyecto y la idea es llegar a los 900
mil millones de dólares la idea oficial
es que china promueve el comercio
internacional a través de los 65 países
que ya se han sumado al proyecto y
aunque la mayor parte de los líderes
occidentales rechazaron participar en
esta cumbre de dos días en la que siguen
pink anunciaba el proyecto hubo otros
grandes líderes que se sumaron sin
reservas entre otros
putin y erdogán
en efecto esto es un encuentro de
grandes mentes en los próximos dos días
espero que intercambiamos puntos de
vista para lograr la iniciativa beltán
road el proyecto del siglo que
beneficiará a las gentes de todo el
mundo xi jinping con china consolidando
su poder y sus relaciones diplomáticas
en la zona es cada vez más difícil que
eeuu pueda mantener su hegemonía en el
mar de china por mucho tiempo si el
ejército chino llegara a superar al
imperio americano
washington perdería todo ese poder
disuasorio del que hemos hablado antes y
esto cambiaría las reglas del comercio
internacional por eso la casa blanca
está muy preocupada con todo esto la cia
ya ha dicho que los dos principales
problemas de eeuu a día de hoy son rusia
y china- y en el caso de china la mayor
preocupación es su intento de ganar
influencia en áfrica y en el océano
índico
[Música]
no somos tan inocentes y estamos tomando
medidas de contrainteligencia para
asegurarnos que tenemos todas las
defensas que necesitamos
thomas bouhail ser comandante general
del ejército estadounidense en áfrica
pero ya sé lo que estáis pensando el
imperio americano llega a todos los
confines del planeta y aquí estamos
hablando únicamente del mar de china y
si me apuras del océano índico por
supuesto tenéis toda la razón en
realidad china solo amenaza la presencia
americana en esta región concreta pero
hablamos de uno de los lugares más
importantes del comercio internacional y
por eso la lucha es más que intensa
pero esperad un momento porque la
historia no termina aquí los chinos no
son tontos saben que si construyen bases
militares demasiado rápido eeuu puede
pedir a sus aliados que hagan lo mismo
eso significaría una escalada militar de
niveles nacho vidal ya nos países como
india y japón se armarían de barcos de
guerra flota aérea y bases militares en
toda la zona y seamos honestos eeuu y
chinas son como la extraña pareja no son
los mejores amigos del mundo pero más o
menos se aguantan el uno al otro pero
tanto japón como la india son enemigos
acérrimos de chinas
[Música]
así que lo último que quiere beijing es
disparar las alarmas y hacer que sus
enemigos se armen a sus puertas y por
eso si jinping mantiene un perfil bajo y
paciente en este tema sabe que hablamos
de algo a largo plazo y ya sabéis que el
largo plazo significa muy largo plazo
tal vez hablamos de un proyecto que
llevaría décadas sin embargo pese a que
el ritmo sea lento más os vale recordar
el término string of per elx el collar
de perlas en los próximos meses lo vais
a ver en todos los medios de
comunicación
[Música]
hablamos de algo tan importante que
incluso al político vamos a dedicarle
una nueva serie de vídeos vamos a cubrir
todos los detalles de este proyecto qué
pasa con los otros países asiáticos qué
es eso que llaman la diplomacia de la
deuda china qué rol jugaría la unión
europea este respecto de todo esto vamos
a hablar muy pronto así que ya sabéis si
no os lo queréis perder suscribiros a
visual político y darle a la campanita
para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones
[Música]
mientras tanto la pregunta es creéis que
este collar de perlas es de verdad una
amenaza para la estabilidad
internacional que puede hacer el imperio
americano al respecto estamos ante el
principio del fin del imperialismo
americano podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios
y por supuesto no olvidéis visitar
nuestra página de patrián para apoyar
este proyecto este año 2019 viene
cargado de sorpresas y queremos contar
con todos vosotros si os gusta visual
política y queréis participar
activamente en esta comunidad patrio es
el lugar indicado si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like compartirlo con
vuestros amigos y como siempre un abrazo
y hasta pronto
[Música]